This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一档 I-Heart 播客。保证真人。在陪伴孩子度过的每个夜晚，准备午餐的背后都充满了悬念。他们终于肯吃蔬菜了吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？便当盒会空着回来、半满着回来，还是根本就不会回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.za for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files.
在你切好黄瓜之前，能听完第 8 集吗？订购 Bell 纯光纤网络，尊享喜爱的 Netflix 和 Disney Plus，每月仅需 94 美元起。两年期网络套餐及自动扣款优惠，价格两年不变。访问 bell.za 了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接意味着一切。我九个月的 captivity 劫后余生，我的一生都在探索其他人是如何在险些摧毁他们的逆境中生存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是《幸存者档案》。
Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Each week, we talk to someone in show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time, and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show.
每周，我都会与经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起，他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，甚至险些被剥夺声音。这些故事讲述了活着逃出生天所需要付出的一切。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。嘿，我是海斯·达芬奇。还有肖恩·克莱门特。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主播。每周，我们都会与业内人士交流，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，并看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都度过了一段美好的时光，没有人因为他们的公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。
We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stillard, and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are. are without us. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们邀请过许多优秀的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼、亚当·斯科特、丹尼·麦克布莱德、本·斯蒂勒，以及许多如果没有我们便不会取得今天成就的大人物。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们将分享女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我在他的摩托车上搭便车。我选择了 B 选项。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的、我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”的空间。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。
Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville, a battle for the future of America plays out in one small town. Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land. We need cities on a shining hill. This is our town, a podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you? Listen to Our Town on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们的家乡不是试管。在纳什维尔东北部 90 英里处，一场关于美国未来的战役在一个小镇上展开。具有右翼背景的开发商购买了数百英亩的土地。我们需要山巅之城。这是我们的镇，这是一档关于当一个小镇成为社会实验的场地并奋起反抗时会发生什么的播客。我想你现在不是搬进了一堆笨蛋乡巴佬里了吧，对吧？在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我们的镇》。
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. A quick reminder, this episode and many others are now on Netflix in video form. And if you want episode transcripts and bonus research, you can find them on substack. Everything will be in the episode description.
大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，这是一档播客节目，我们将探讨二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析二十多岁的心理学。温馨提示，本期节目以及许多其他节目现在都已在 Netflix 上推出视频版。如果你想要节目文稿和额外研究资料，可以在 Substack 上找到它们。所有内容都将列在节目简介中。
So I'm going to begin this episode with a question. when was the last time you were fully, truly alone for longer than 12 hours? When was the last time you spent a whole weekend by yourself, a whole day by yourself even? And more specifically, when was the last time you did that and enjoyed yourself? Our relationship to loneliness, but more specifically just being by ourselves, just being alone. Maybe not lonely, but alone, impacts our 20s in ways that you cannot imagine. Or maybe you can. It influences the partner we choose.
所以，我将用一个问题来开始这期节目：你上一次完全、真正地一个人呆超过 12 小时是什么时候？你上一次独自度过整个周末，甚至是整整一天是什么时候？更具体地说，你上一次这样做并乐在其中是什么时候？我们与孤独的关系，更具体地说是仅仅和自己在一起、仅仅独处的关系，以你无法想象的方式影响着我们的二十多岁。或者也许你能想象。它影响着我们选择的伴侣。
It influences the friendships that we keep, naturally, of course. But also the jobs we refuse to leave, the cities we never move to, the dreams we never pursue because they might require us to spend some time by ourselves. Sometimes our biggest decisions, without us even realizing it, aren't driven by. what we truly want, but by what will prevent us from feeling lonely or being alone. It might seem funny. It's kind of ironic even to say that we have a relationship with loneliness, but we do, every single one of us. There are some people who jump for joy at the thought of uninterrupted time by themselves all weekend, all week, they could do it forever. But if you're like me or the average person, I think solitude feels less like a blessing, more like a second
它自然而然地影响着我们维持的友谊。但同样也影响着我们拒绝离开的工作，我们从未搬去过的城市，我们从未追求的梦想，因为这些可能需要我们花一些时间独处。有时，我们最重要的决定，甚至在我们自己意识到之前，并不是由我们真正想要什么驱动的，而是由什么能阻止我们感到孤独或独处驱动的。这看起来可能很搞笑。甚至有点讽刺地说，我们与孤独有着某种关系，但我们的确如此，我们每一个人。有些人一想到整个周末、整整一周都有不被打扰的独处时间就会高兴得跳起来，他们可以永远这样下去。但如果你和我或普通人一样，我认为独处给人的感觉与其说是福分，不如说是第二个
best option at best, a punishment at worse. Today, though, I want to talk about how we can get over that and how we can truly transform our relationship with loneliness to not just be something that we tolerate, but something we deeply enjoy, perhaps even benefit from in its entirety. I also want to talk specifically about what you will gain from loneliness or from solitude and some very practical ways to get there. Because if you can choose your reaction to solitude, to isolation, to being alone, you gain a psychological power and a psychological flexibility that very few people have, especially in this day and age, where everyone is connected to each other at literally every hour, every minute of every day. So without further ado, I'm very excited for this
退而求其次的选择（如果算好的话），最糟糕的时候则是一种惩罚。不过今天，我想谈谈我们如何克服这一点，以及我们如何真正转变我们与孤独的关系，让它不仅仅是我们容忍的东西，而是我们深深喜爱、甚至可能从中全面受益的东西。我还想具体谈谈你将从孤独或独处中获得什么，以及实现这一目标的非常切实的方法。因为如果你能选择自己对独处、对孤立、对一个人呆着的反应，你就会获得一种极少数人（尤其是在这个每个人在一天中的每一小时、每一分钟都与他人紧密相连的当下）所不具备的心理力量和心理灵活性。所以，废话不多说，我非常期待
episode, let's get into the psychology behind how you can get better at being alone. So to begin, why does feeling alone feel so just like icky and feel so weird? Why do we at times feel like we need to run away from any instance of solitude or alone time or isolation? Let us do the simplest explanation first. And one that you've likely heard quite a few times from me. Being alone goes against deep survival instincts to stay with the herd. Those survival instincts influence us unconsciously to always gravitate back towards the group, back towards being around people. Some people even have such an intense instinct towards others or such an intense fear of being alone that it can develop into a phobia. It's called
这期节目，让我们深入探讨如何更好地享受独处的心理学。那么首先，为什么感觉孤独会让人觉得那么糟糕、那么奇怪？为什么我们有时会觉得需要逃避任何形式的独处、孤单时光或隔绝？让我们先做最简单的解释。这也是你可能已经从我这里听过好几次的一个解释。独处违背了与群体待在一起的深度生存本能。这些生存本能无意识地影响着我们，让我们总是倾向于回到群体中，回到有人的环境中。有些人甚至对他人有着如此强烈的本能，或者对独处有着如此强烈的恐惧，以至于发展成了某种恐惧症。这被称为
autophobia or monophobia. This creates intense anxiety, intense panic about being by ourselves or intense fear around not being around other people. That's the first explanation. In my opinion, and I know I mentioned the evolutionary explanation for loneliness quite a bit, but the older I get, the more I'm kind of leaning away from this theory, I think this idea that like we only hate loneliness because it goes against survival instincts is a little bit outdated. It doesn't really consider the role of introversion. It doesn't really consider why some people actually like being by themselves. It doesn't explain why loneliness persists even when we are constantly around people physically, especially nowadays considering the availability of smartphones and like how far we've
恐独症或广场恐惧症。这会围绕我们独自一人产生强烈的焦虑、恐慌，或者围绕身边没有其他人产生强烈的恐惧。这是第一个解释。在我看来，我知道我经常提到孤独的演化解释，但随着我年龄的增长，我越来越倾向于抛弃这个理论。我认为这种“我们只讨厌孤独是因为它违背了生存本能”的观点有点过时了。它并没有真正考虑到内向的作用，也没有真正考虑到为什么有些人实际上喜欢独处。它无法解释为什么即使我们身体上经常和别人在一起，孤独感仍然挥之不去，尤其是现在考虑到智能手机的普及，以及我们与在世界或平原上游牧、以部落为单位生活的时代相比已经
come from roaming the world or roaming the plains and in tribes. It doesn't really, it doesn't seem as applicable? Like, there is another element to this going on. Additionally, a fun fact for you, according to the UN, 60% of the world lives in densely populated spaces. And that would mean 60% of people shouldn't be lonely, right? It's very easy to see other people. It's very easy to be around them, to feel enmeshed in a tribe. So this idea of just physically being alone, feeling threatening is inaccurate, considering that a lot of us aren't physically alone. It is the sense of being emotionally isolated and emotionally unsupported that feels scary. And yes, there may be an evolutionary explanation for that. It's not the entire thing. I think why we shrink from our
走得有多远。这似乎，似乎没那么适用了？就像，这里面还有另一个因素在起作用。此外，给你一个有趣的事实，根据联合国的数据，世界上有 60% 的人口生活在人口稠密的地区。这意味着 60% 的人本不该感到孤独，对吧？看到别人很容易。和他们在一起、感觉自己融入一个部落很容易。因此，考虑到我们许多人身体上并不是一个人，这种仅仅因为身体上独处而感到受到威胁的想法是不准确的。真正让人感到可怕的是那种被情感孤立、在情感上得不到支持的感觉。是的，这背后可能有一种演化上的解释。但这并不是全部原因。我认为我们之所以对
alone time really comes down to an impending sense that this could be our new normal and that any further slow escalation of this solitude could leave us entirely isolated before we even realize it. Before we know it, one night in turns into a month of complete isolation and we won't have any say in the matter. I don't think it helps that in this day and age, we seem to both culturally and socially villainize solitude and loneliness. And I think this is for a few reasons as well. Firstly, there is the most common but largely fair assumption that people, any person you see who is alone isn't alone by choice. They are alone because nobody wants to spend time with them. That is the assumption that we make. This, of course, then makes us feel more fearful of being
独处时光退避三舍，真正归结于一种迫在眉睫的感觉：这可能会成为我们的新常态，并且这种独处状态的任何进一步缓慢升级都可能让我们在甚至还没意识到之前就彻底陷入孤立。不知不觉中，一个晚上的独处就变成了整整一个月完全的与世隔绝，而对此我们毫无发言权。我觉得，在这个时代，我们在文化和社会上似乎都将独处和孤独妖魔化了，这并不是什么好事。我想这也是出于几个原因。首先，存在着最常见但很大程度上算合理的假设：你看到的任何独自一人的都不是出于自愿。他们独处是因为没有人想和他们共度时光。这是我们做出的假设。
alone ourselves because we think that others will see us at the movies out for dinner and think something is wrong with them. Something has gone wrong in their life or recently. The Society for Personality and Social Psychology actually conducted a study in 2022 on the social costs of seeking solitude, and their research showed that others assume that solitude seekers, people who like spending time alone, actually don't care much about belonging to a group. They might assume that they're less friendly. Importantly, these negative impressions were often very incorrect, but the snap judgment persisted anyways. and influenced how people treated those of us who seek solitude. A critical way that this happened
当然，这反过来又让我们对独处本身感到更加恐惧，因为我们认为其他人会看到我们在看电影、外出吃饭，并认为他们身上出了什么问题。他们的生活或最近发生了一些不好的事情。人格与社会心理学协会实际上在 2022 年进行了一项关于寻求独处的社会成本的研究，他们的研究表明，其他人会认为寻求独处的人——也就是喜欢花时间独处的人——其实并不太在乎融入一个群体。他们可能会认为这些人不那么友好。重要的是，这些负面印象往往非常不准确，但这种草率的判断还是持续了下来，并影响了人们对待我们这些寻求独处之人的方式。这种情况发生的一个关键方式
is that people see others on their own. They believe that these people want to be left alone. That leads to them being left out, therefore creating what we think will be a self-reinforcing cycle, one that we don't want to happen to us. You know, we voluntarily spend time alone. Soon, it's not going to be so voluntary anymore. It's going to be something that happens all the time. The other way that we villainize solitude is through the language that we use to describe people who spend time with themselves, and it's not very nice language. Think of the phrase, you know, lone wolf to describe somebody who just like suddenly goes and shoots up a school because they're a loner, another word that's not particularly nice.
是人们看到其他人独自一人。他们认为这些人希望被独自留在这里。这导致他们被排挤，从而创造出我们认为会发生的那种自我强化的循环——一种我们不希望发生在自己身上的循环。你知道的，我们自愿花时间独处。很快，这就不会再那么自愿了。它将变成一种一直发生的事情。我们妖魔化独处的另一种方式是通过我们用来描述那些花时间与自己相处之人的语言，而且这些语言并不怎么好听。想想“独行狼”这个词，用来形容某人突然去学校开枪，因为他们是个独行者——另一个不怎么动听的词。
Women are often branded as like, you're a crazy cat lady, you're a spinster if you choose to live alone, particularly if they are romantically unattached, if they spend time. by themselves, as if they are alone because they are undesirable and being undesirable is the worst thing in the world. All of this language, and that's just three examples, you know, influences our decision to pursue solitude or not, because we don't want to be disapproved of. We don't want to be seen in a way that is negative by our peers or by other people and that we see other people treated. Researchers have also argued that solitude has gotten a very bad reputation, because we haven't made a deep enough distinction between solitude and loneliness.
女性经常被贴上这样的标签：“你是个疯狂的猫夫人”，如果你选择独自生活，尤其是如果她们在感情上没有伴侣、如果她们花时间，就会被称为老处女。
They are seen as synonymous when they are so different. We know loneliness has some serious health consequences. It has even been compared to, you know, smoking a pack of cigarettes a day in a very famous study. We know loneliness just feels awful when we're in it. It's not something we want to subject ourselves to. But solitude doesn't feel the same way and doesn't have the same health impact. you can feel incredibly socially connected and still really enjoy being alone. You can have two, three, really good relationships, spend most of your time by yourself,
独自一人，就好像她们独处是因为她们不受欢迎，而受欢迎与否是世界上最糟糕的事情。所有这些语言——这只是三个例子——都影响了我们是否追求独处的决定，因为我们不想不被认可。我们不想被同龄人或其他人以负面的方式看待，也不想看到其他人受到那样的对待。研究人员还辩称，独处之所以名声大噪，是因为我们没有对独处和孤独做出足够深刻的区分。
and still not categorize yourself as lonely or experience the health risks that lonely people do. So spending time alone has a bit of a PR problem, I would say, even though, to be honest, like we rarely are truly alone anymore. Like, it is very rare, like the question I asked at the beginning, to spend time by ourselves emotionally, but physically, we are all in some way or another keeping tabs on those around us. We have a sense of what other people are doing at all times through social media, through texting, through the news cycle, which tells us what somebody in a far-off place is doing whilst we're cooking. There is this constant deep sense of social interconnectedness. It has never been more overwhelming and it heightens our need to be seen as social, to be seen as busy and popular because it seems like everybody else is.
它们被视为同义词，但它们截然不同。我们知道孤独会带来一些严重的健康后果。在一项非常著名的研究中，它甚至被比作每天吸一包烟。我们知道孤独在身处其中时感觉糟糕透顶。这不是我们想要强加给自己的东西。但独处的感觉并不一样，也没有相同的健康影响。你可以感到与社会的社交联系非常紧密，却依然非常享受独处。你可以拥有两三个真正的好关系，把大部分时间留给自己，
This is really apparent in our 20s, of course, because we feel this need to like live up to this depiction of this decade as the busiest most social years of our lives. This is the social peak. That's what people want it to seem like. This is what people claim it to be like. You are never going to have more friends than you have now. you are never going to be as busy as now, so you better lean into that. Being alone can definitely feel upsetting deeply when we are truly lacking connection. But in my opinion, and from what I'm
却仍然不会把自己归类为孤独，也不会经历孤独者所面临的健康风险。因此，花时间独处确实存在一点公关问题，我可以说，尽管说实话，就像我们现在很少真正孤单一样。就像，正如我在开头所问的问题那样，在情感上花时间独处是非常罕见的，但在身体上，我们都在以某种方式关注着周围的人。我们通过社交媒体、通过短信、通过新闻循环，有一种对其他人一直在做什么的感觉，新闻告诉我们当我们在做饭时，远方某个人在做什么。这种持续的、深层的社会互联感从未如此令人应接不暇，它加剧了我们被视为善于社交、被视为忙碌和受欢迎的需求，因为似乎其他所有人都是如此。
seeing, more and more, the negative reaction it gives us is just guilt and shame, as if we are not making the most of our lives, as if we aren't worthy of being around people all the time. We're ruining this period when we should have the most connections, which means we run back to connections that don't make us that happy either. So what do we miss when we neglect our alone time? What do we not get to enjoy? Number one, when we flee time spent by ourselves, we just never get adjusted to our own company.
这在我们的二十多岁时当然非常明显，因为我们觉得有必要不辜负这个十年的描绘——将其视为我们一生中最忙碌、最社交的年份。这是社交的巅峰。这就是人们希望它看起来的样子。这就是人们声称的样子。你将永远不会拥有比现在更多的朋友，你将永远不会像现在这样忙碌，所以你最好顺应这一点。当我们真正缺乏联系时，独处绝对会让人感到深深的心烦意乱。但在我看来，从我所
We never feel calm within ourselves. You never feel just like comfortable doing things alone, going to the movies, going to the markets, going out for coffee because they are simply, you know, the things that we should be doing with other people. We constantly have this like third eye or this sense of a of a camera or some social surveillance on us that's going to come down at any moment and say, you're doing that by yourself. You must be lonely. If we constantly rush to fill our social calendar or days or lives because we want to avoid this feeling,
看到的来看，越来越多的时候，它给我们带来的负面反应只是内疚和羞耻，就好像我们没有充分利用我们的生活，就好像我们不配一直和别人在一起。我们正在毁掉这个本该拥有最多社交联系的时期，这意味着我们又跑回了那些并不能让我们那么快乐的人际关系中。那么，当我们忽视独处时间时，我们错过了什么？我们错过了什么享受？第一，当我们逃避独处的时间时，我们永远无法适应自己的陪伴。
we also experience this rebound effect where more and more being alone does feel like a punishment it does feel like we're doing something wrong. The less practice we get at being alone, the less we can cope with it when it does incidentally or inevitably happen, meaning that in those moments, alone time feels more threatening because we just don't have the practice of being by ourselves. We haven't gotten used to it.
我们在内心深处永远不会感到平静。你永远不会觉得独自做事情、去看电影、去集市、出去喝咖啡很自在，因为这些简直是，你知道，我们应该和别人一起做的事情。我们的头脑中不断有这样一只“第三只眼”或一种摄像头的感知，或者某种社会的监视落在我们身上，随时准备降临并说：“你一个人在做这件事。你一定很孤独。”如果我们不断地赶着填满我们的社交日程、日子或生活，因为我们想要避开这种感觉，
So it creates this cycle of like, avoid this more because when I do experience it, it's so bad because I never experience it. You also never get a proper chance to regulate. Humans emotionally regulate in a lot of ways, but typically in two directions. We either co-regulate or we self-regulate. Simply put, we either use other people for regulation and steadiness. We rely on their presence to help us calm down.
我们也会经历这种反弹效应：独处越来越像是一种惩罚，越来越像是我们做错了什么。我们练习独处得越少，当它偶然或不可避免地发生时，我们就越无法应付它，这意味着在那些时刻，独处时光让人感觉更有威胁性，因为我们只是没有独处的练习。我们还没有习惯它。
We center our thoughts based on them. They make us feel okay. That's co-regulation. Or we use internal strategies to do that independently. We see that we're not feeling well or feeling, in distress, we go for a walk, we speak positively to ourselves, we do our breathing, we do our self-care, we can bring ourselves down and we can also bring ourselves up. If you always borrow your regulation from other people, alone time is going to begin to feel more and more
所以它创造了一个这样的循环：更多地避开它，因为当我真正经历它时它是如此糟糕，而我却从未经历过它。你也永远没有一个合适的机会来调节自己。人类在情感上有多种调节方式，但通常有两个方向。我们要么共调节，要么自我调节。简单来说，我们要么利用其他人来进行调节和稳定。我们依靠他们的存在来帮助我们平静下来。
dangerous because when presented with an uncomfortable emotion, during that time, when you are by yourself, you have fewer and fewer and fewer internal resources to self-regulate or to process it. Alternatively, when we spend time on our own, you know, we can also foster better emotional independence. This is something that we gain through a long time because we are forced to become our own primary source of validation, primary source of comfort and stability, not all the time, but in times when we really need it. This contributes to another kind of issue. which is that when we are surrounded by others constantly, we also just have less mental space to self-reflect because we are forever getting social input on everything that we're doing.
我们以他们为中心来调整我们的想法。他们让我们觉得一切都好。这就是共调节。或者我们利用内部策略来独立完成这一点。我们看到自己感觉不好或感到痛苦，我们去散步，我们对自己进行积极的对话，我们做呼吸练习，我们做自我关怀，我们可以让自己平静下来，也可以让自己振作起来。如果你总是从别人那里借用你的调节，独处时光就会开始变得越来越
This might include, you know, others' opinions about what should we eat? What should I wear? What do you think about this? What should we do? Even subtle cues are like, when you're around people, you act differently because you're monitoring your behavior. You're trying to fit in. even with your best, best friend, you're still trying to abide by social norms. You may not think you are, but cognitively there is a tax. There is a tax when you're around people of understanding that they are perceiving you as you are perceiving them. There is this very notable TED talk from Susan Kane. She is the author of the book, The Power of Introverts, where she basically says that
危险，因为当你在独处时遇到一种不舒服的情绪，你的内部资源会变得越来越少、越来越少，无法自我调节或处理它。相反，当我们花时间独处时，你知道，我们也能培养更好的情感独立性。这是我们通过长时间的独处所获得的东西，因为我们被迫成为自己主要的验证来源、主要的安慰和稳定来源，不是所有时间，而是当我们真正需要它的时候。这导致了另一种问题，
if you want to find out how you really feel about something, whether it's a relationship, a choice, an opinion, you have to seclude yourself to some degree for some period of time. She emphasizes that solitude, even introversion, like isn't something that needs to be cured. This isn't something that needs to be avoided. You need to understand that the ability to be quiet and to look inwards and for silence and to just be by yourself allows for greater. understanding and it's a lost art, it's a lost skill to just sit with yourself and be like, what do I think? What do I want? How am I going to cope with this? There's also a lot of
那就是当我们不断被其他人包围时，我们也只是有更少的心理空间来进行自我反思，因为我们在对我们所做的每一件事上永远都在接受社会的输入。这可能包括，你知道，其他人关于我们应该吃什么？我应该穿什么？你觉得这个怎么样？我们应该做什么？甚至是一些微妙的暗示，比如当你和别人在一起时，你的行为会有所不同，因为你在监控自己的行为。你试图融入其中。即使是你最好、最好的朋友，你仍然在努力遵守社会规范。你可能认为自己没有，但在认知上是有代价的。当你身边有人时，理解他们正在感知你，就像你正在感知他们一样，这是有代价的。
evidence that the more you not just tolerate but actually enjoy a lone time, which is a practice we know, but the more you enjoy it, the more emotionally intelligent you may be, the more creative you may be, and the more discerning you may be as well. I want to talk about one piece of research on this specifically. It's from the English pediatrician and psychoanalyst, Donald Winnicott, we talk about him all the time. And it's his idea of, it's just called the capacity to be alone. He first spoke about this concept, the capacity to be alone in the 1950s. He wrote about it in the paper of the same name. And he essentially said, if I'm looking at somebody and I want to know if they're going to end up being smart as an adult, if I'm looking at a child and I want
苏珊·凯恩有一个非常著名的 TED 演讲。她是《内向者的力量》一书的作者，她在演讲中基本上说过，如果你想找出你对某事的真正感受，无论是关系、选择还是意见，你必须在某种程度上、在一段时间内让自己隐退。她强调说，独处，甚至是内向，都不是需要被治愈的东西。这不是需要被回避的东西。你需要明白，安静、向内看、保持沉默以及仅仅和自己在一起的能力可以带来更多
know, are they going to be successful? I'm going to look at whether they have a capacity to self-regulate and whether they have a capacity to self-intertain. Now, obviously, he didn't want to see it go too far, but what he basically said is that when he saw children, toddlers, even teenagers, who could feel good enough within themselves, who could see that, like, maybe their presence wasn't wanted and they could go off and self-intertain, go off into their own minds, think critically about something who seemed to really enjoy their own company, those were the people that he said often ended up becoming very creative and very intelligent because they didn't require the presence of others to entertain them and they didn't require the presence of others to confirm
的理解，而坐下来面对自己并问“我是怎么想的？我想要什么？我要如何应对这个？”是一种失传的艺术，是一种失传的技能。还有很多
their reality or to confirm their existence. Now, this is from a little while ago, so it's been revised a few times and I think a lot of people in the modern day understand that, you know, this was at a time of like very intense individualism and everybody was like you need to be this like solo individual you are you know a boat in the ocean and now we understand that it's a lot more complex than that but i do still think it raises a really important point at some stage in your life you are going to be lonely you are going to be alone you are going to experience solitude if you have never practiced that sensation before if you think of that purely as punishment or that you're doing something wrong, there is a lot that you can gain
证据表明，你不仅越能容忍而且越能真正享受独处时光——我们知道这是一门练习，但你越享受它，你的情商可能就越高，你的创造力可能就越强，你的洞察力也可能就越敏锐。我想具体谈谈关于这一点的一项研究。它来自英国儿科医生兼精神分析学家唐纳德·温尼科特，我们经常谈论他。这就是他的观点，被称为“独处的能力”。他在 20 世纪 50 年代首次谈到这个概念，即独处的能力。他在同名论文中写到了这一点。他基本上说过，如果我看着某人，我想知道他们成年后是否会变得聪明，如果我看着一个孩子，我想
from that that is just simply not going to be accessible for you. So I think that's a better kind of interpretation of Winnicott's theory. Interesting nonetheless. Okay, we're going to take a short break here and then we're going to discuss three of the other benefits that you have to gain from regular alone time if it's not already part of your kind of social diet. And just how to get better at it when maybe like me, it's not something that you are naturally good at. So stay with us. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode eight before you're done
知道，他们会成功吗？我会观察他们是否具备自我调节的能力以及是否具备自我娱乐的能力。现在，很显然，他并不希望这种能力走向极端，但他基本上所说的是，当他看到那些能够在内心感到足够好、能够看到也许他们的存在并不被需要、并且能够走开去进行自我娱乐、走进他们自己的内心世界、批判性地思考某事、并且似乎真的很享受自己陪伴的孩子、幼儿甚至青少年时，那些就是他说的人，他们最终往往会变得非常有创造力和非常聪明，因为他们不需要别人的存在来娱乐他们，他们也不需要别人的存在来证实
slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinheiro and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us.
他们的现实或证实他们的存在。现在，这已经是前一段时间的观点了，所以它已经被修正了好几次，我认为现代的许多人都理解，你知道，这是在一个极其个人主义的时期，每个人都觉得你需要成为这样一个孤独的个体，你是一艘在海洋中的小船，而现在我们了解到这要复杂得多。但我仍然认为它提出了一个非常重要的问题：在你生命中的某个阶段，你将会感到孤独，你将会孤身一人，你将会经历独处。如果你以前从未练习过那种感觉，如果你纯粹认为那是一种惩罚或者你做错了什么，那么你将从中获得很多
Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is, and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to be. book your first trip. I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and
根本无法为你所接触到的东西。所以我觉得这是对温尼科特理论的一个更好的诠释。尽管如此，它还是很有趣的。好吧，我们在这里要休息一下，然后我们将讨论如果你还没有将定期独处纳入你的某种社交“饮食”中，你从定期的独处时间中获得的另外三个好处。以及当你像我一样，这并不是你天生擅长的事情时，如何才能做得更好。所以请继续收听。陪伴孩子度过的每个夜晚，准备午餐的背后都充满了悬念。他们终于肯吃蔬菜了吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？便当盒会空着回来、半满着回来，还是根本就不会回来？
Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connected the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From best-selling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is
在你切好黄瓜之前，能听完第 8 集吗？订购 Bell 纯光纤网络，尊享喜爱的 Netflix 和 Disney Plus，每月仅需 94 美元起。两年期网络套餐及自动扣款优惠，价格两年不变。访问 bell.ca 了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接意味着一切。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们将分享女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我在他的摩托车上搭便车。我选择了 B 选项。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的、我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”的空间。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。每次我试图独自一人时，我总是遇到人，他们总是对我说：“你对我们笑了。”
a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months.
这附近没有多少人会笑。正是在你独自一人时，你对世界的本来面目最具接受力，而不是对兜售给你的关于它的谎言最具接受力。这可以是一段你挑战极限、改变想法或唤醒一个全新自己的时间。因此，无论你是一名独自旅行的老手，还是你太紧张而不敢预订你的第一次旅行。我希望你能在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。如果你的书架和你的 For You 页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是 Prose Society，这是一档每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是思想女儿、流行文化痴迷者以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和
I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice, next to my ear saying shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming.
《恋爱岛》值得同等程度探讨的人的群聊。我是伊莉·拉罗，每周我们都在书籍、互联网和每个人都停不下来讨论的对话之间建立联系。我得去查查这个故事。我着迷了。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和您最喜欢的 BookTok 创作者到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可能的。就像如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的讯息，那么这就是
They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook on the Big Money Players Network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners.
一个特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度探讨、聪明的流行文化对话，还是寻找一群喜欢过度思考的读者社区，你都来对地方了。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Pro Society。在字里行间见。当我 14 岁时，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。
Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip the script? What is the surprise woman? Actually, you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird.
我活了下来，我花了一生时间探索其他人是如何在险些摧毁他们的逆境中生存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得那个低沉、嘲弄的声音在我耳边说，闭嘴，什么也别说。每周，我都会与经历过不可思议之万劫不复的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始觉得我的床头有人，然后我开始尖叫。
Adam Scott. This entire time, you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to the, visit the show. I would never expect. I would never set expectations for something like that to happen. If the universe allows for something like that to happen, I'm open to it.
他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，甚至险些被剥夺声音。但这些不是关于从他们身上被夺走的东西的故事。这些是关于活着逃出生天所需要付出的一切的故事。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。嘿，我是海斯·达芬奇。还有肖恩·克莱门特。我们是 Big Money Players Network 旗下播客《好莱坞手册》的主播。我们的节目对初次听众极其友好。
I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah, it's all this fragile masculinity. Exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, is that weed? Nope, it's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no.
每周，我们都会与业内人士（又称“行业内幕”）交流，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，并看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都度过了一段美好的时光，没有人因为他们的公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们邀请过许多优秀的嘉宾，比如莎拉·谢尔曼，其实也不是那么好。事实上，你能帮我塑造这个吗？我们怎么把它翻转过来，对吧？我们怎么把剧本反转过来？什么是惊喜女性？其实，你认为是直男的那个人其实才是行为怪异的人。
Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? They're like, oh, what's a state? Everyone's so dumb except for you. And fake. Right, fake and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us.
亚当·斯科特。这段时间以来，你一直期待亚当·桑德勒来节目参观。我绝不会期待。我绝不会对这种事情的发生抱有期望。如果宇宙允许这种事情发生，我是持开放态度的。
Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Alongside the links between spending time alone and intelligence, the other thing I briefly mentioned right before the break was creativity. It is no coincidence that so many writers and painters and musicians talk about these periods of intense solitude in their lives or these periods of like needing to withdraw or needing to send to themselves to really find a deeper well before
我随时会接受。你知道，丹尼·麦克布莱德，很好。是的，这一切都是脆弱的男子气概。散发着。老实说，我走在走廊上就能闻到。我在想，那是大麻吗？不，那是脆弱的男子气概。本·斯蒂勒，不。
they produced amazing art. That's why so many great albums came out during COVID or after a breakup or after long retreats from public eye. Studies have shown that as long as your alone time isn't driven by fear and isn't driven by avoidance, it deeply stimulates creativity because there is this increased looseness to your thoughts. Our brains start to entertain themselves, start to get more imaginative. And in the absence of social pressure or social stimulation, like they just start to feel a little bit more at E's. There was an Italian study from 2000 titled Solitude as a Positive Experience, and it found that solitude creates more conditions for authenticity, imagination, fascination, and obsession,
因为很多时候在没有语境的情况下，人们并不理解，甚至不知道什么是圈子。你知道我的意思吗？他们会说，哦，什么是州？每个人都很蠢，除了你。还有虚假。没错，虚假而且也不感兴趣，或者只是说，“哦，我有我自己的生活。我不在乎你的生活。”以及许多其他如果没有我们便不会取得现在成就的大人物。
all of which help with creativity. They were also able to distinguish why loneliness doesn't do the same thing for people. In their words, solitude is characterized by presence, which makes creativity easier. Loneliness is characterized by absence and longing and rumination, which makes creativity harder. Not impossible because a lot of lonely people also make great art, but harder. Another paper from the University of Texas also found that solitude promotes creativity because it allows for what they call, and I love this phrase, the incubation of ideas. Basically, ideas have time to settle, They have time to grow and to develop in isolation from other people before they're kind of out and present it to the world.
哦，顺便说一句，威尔·费瑞尔亲自告诉我们他喜欢这个节目，并且他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他实在太忙了。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。除了独处与智力之间的联系之外，我在休息前简要提到的另一件事就是创造力。绝非巧合的是，如此多的作家、画家和音乐家都在谈论他们生活中那些经历极度孤独的时期，或者那些需要退隐或需要回归自我以寻找更深泉源的时期，然后他们才能创作出惊人的艺术作品。这就是为什么如此多的伟大专辑都是在新冠疫情期间、失恋后或长期淡出公众视野后问世的。研究表明，只要你的独处时间不是由恐惧驱动的，也不是由逃避驱动的，它就会极大地激发创造力，因为你的思绪变得更加松散。我们的大脑开始自娱自乐，变得更有想象力。在没有社会压力或社会刺激的情况下，它们开始感觉稍微自在了一些。
There's a couple of other mental processes they say contribute. They talk about this thing called the enhanced ability for the mind to wonder. They talk about drifting attention. It all links back to when you are by yourself, some of the walls come down and creative insight is channeled through you. An added bonus to being alone too is that. become much more socially selective. When we develop the ability to be happy by ourselves, nobody else can take that from you. We really do start to realize, like, what I previously accepted,
有一项 2000 年的意大利研究，题为《作为积极体验的独处》，研究发现，独处为真实性、想象力、迷恋和痴迷创造了更多条件，所有这些都有助于创造力。他们还能够区分为什么孤独不会为人们做同样的事情。用他们的话来说，独处以“存在”为特征，这使创造力变得更容易。孤独则以“缺席”、“渴望”和“反刍思维”为特征，这使创造力变得更加困难。并非不可能，因为许多孤独的人也创作出伟大的艺术，但确实更困难。得克萨斯大学的另一篇论文也发现，独处之所以能促进创造力，是因为它允许他们所说的——我非常喜欢这个短语——“想法的孵化”。基本上，想法在与其他人隔离的情况下，有时间沉淀下来，有时间成长和发展，然后再被带出来并呈现给世界。
why did I accept that? Those people didn't like me. Those people weren't nice to me. I don't want to be around those people. I was just afraid of being alone. And so we're really able to cultivate a deeper a sense of self-worth. When solitude stops feeling like a void that you are desperate to fill, I think it becomes a filter instead. It becomes a way of testing whether people and certain commitments in your life are actually worth it to you. Because if you've got this great alternative of like, I'm going to spend some time by myself and that's amazing, not doing that requires something really special. And so it means that the things that you let into your life, the standard for them is higher. When being by yourself feels so amazing, I think it just takes a bit more to drag you
还有其他几个心理过程被认为对此有所贡献。他们谈到了所谓的思维神游能力的增强。他们谈到了注意力的漂移。这一切都回溯到当你独自一人时，某些防御墙倒塌了，创造性的洞察力便通过你传导出来。独处的另一个额外好处是，你。变得更加具有社交选择性。当我们培养出独自一人也能快乐的能力时，没有人能把这一点从真正夺走。我们确实开始意识到，比如，我以前接受的那些，
away from that. And so your life might get smaller, but it gets bigger in terms of quality. The irony is, I think our ability to be alone actually creates healthier relationships, which people don't always talk about. When we get better at being solo, we really start to be selective about who we're choosing to join us. Relationships are always a necessity. We don't want to be completely hyper-independent. But now we're in this state of like abundance rather than desperation. It's like, well, of course I want to have great friendships.
我为什么要接受那个？那些人不喜欢我。那些人对我并不好。我不想和那些人在一起。我只是害怕孤独。因此，我们确实能够培养出更深层次的自尊感。当独处不再像一个你迫切想要填补的虚空时，我认为它反而变成了一个过滤器。它变成了一种测试方法，用来检验你生活中的某些人和某些承诺对你来说是否真的值得。因为如果你有了这样一个绝佳的替代方案，比如“我要花点时间独处，那太棒了”，那么不这样做就需要一些真正特别的东西。因此，这意味着你放进生活中的东西，其标准会更高。当独处感觉如此美妙时，我想需要更多的力量才能把你从那种状态中拉开。所以你的生活可能会变小，但在质量方面它变大了。具有讽刺意味的是，我认为我们独处的能力实际上创造了更健康的人际关系，这是人们并不总是谈论的。当我们变得更擅长独处时，我们真的开始对选择谁来加入我们变得挑剔。人际关系永远是一种必需品。我们不想变得完全过度独立。但现在我们处于一种丰盛而非绝望的状态。就像，当然我想拥有美好的友谊。
Of course I want to be around people. But I know that I can get that and have that and maybe need less of that than I previously did because my inner well is so deep and because the joy I get from being around myself is so valuable that if something, somebody isn't going to add to that, I actually don't think I'm going to be pained. Whereas previously, if you were somebody like me, it was just like anybody I can get. If that means I don't have to be by myself and I don't have to face a single raw thought, good enough for me. You could literally insult me. You could literally talk about me behind my back. As long as you were between
我当然想和人们在一起。但我知道，我可以获得并拥有这些，而且可能比以前需要得更少，因为我的内心之井是如此深邃，我从陪伴自己中获得的快乐是如此宝贵，以至于如果某事或某人不能为之增添价值，我其实并不觉得痛苦。然而在此之前，如果你像我一样，就会觉得只要能抓到一个就行。如果这意味着我不必独自一人，不必直面任何一个赤裸裸的想法，这就足够好了。你甚至可以当面侮辱我。你甚至可以在背后议论我。只要你挡在
me and my own feelings and thoughts about something, you were doing a good job. This is such a crucial point to be made before I go into how to actually prioritize and enjoy your solitude. I will say this is a very critical point that we need to make right here, right now, before we go into how to actually prioritize and enjoy our solitude. You don't want to go far too far the other way. Been there as well, I'm sure some of you have also. You're not meant to constantly be around other people. You're also not meant to be hyper-independent.
我和自己关于某事的感受与想法之间，你就做得很好。在我探讨如何真正优先考虑并享受独处之前，必须要指出这一点，这至关重要。我要说的是，在我们探讨如何真正优先考虑并享受独处之前，此时此刻，我们需要指出这一点，这是一个非常关键的观点。你可别走向另一个极端。我也经历过，我相信你们中有些人也经历过。你不需要时刻和别人在一起。你也不需要表现得过度独立。
Sometimes when we get really good at enjoying our own time and space, it molds and it evolves into this thing where we're only relying on ourselves. And we really get this attitude of like, I don't need anybody. I don't need help with this. I can do this by myself. Other people are just going to drag me down. We're aiming for healthy dependency here. That is balance. Balance is like at the core of human existence.
有时，当我们非常擅长享受自己的时间和空间时，它就会塑造并演变成这样一种状态：我们只依赖自己。我们真的会产生这种态度，比如，我不需要任何人。我不需要别人帮我做这个。我自己就能搞定。其他人只会拖我的后腿。我们在这里追求的是健康的依赖。这就是平衡。平衡可以说是人类生存的核心。
We are striving for relationships that fill up. us as deeply as our alone time does and a striving for relationships where you feel equally, yeah, I guess fulfilled by them, but also you find that it gives you good thoughts to go away from that makes your alone time easier because you know that you have the support network and you have these people who love you. And so again, there's not this desperation of like, at any point I could be cast out at any point these people might not like me anymore. So I better take what I can get. You lose that feeling and I think both of these interconnected things of connection and solitude become richer because each is becoming more fulfilling on its own.
我们正在努力寻找能像独处一样深深充实我们的关系，并努力寻找这样一种关系：你觉得同样能从中获得，嗯，我猜是满足感，但你也会发现它能带给你很好的想法，让你在离开时能让独处变得更容易，因为你知道自己拥有支持网络，拥有这些爱你的人。因此，这里同样没有那种绝望感，觉得随时可能被抛弃，随时这些人可能就不再喜欢我了。所以我最好有什么就要什么。你失去了那种感觉，而且我认为，联系和独处这两个相互交织的方面都会变得更加丰富，因为每一方都在独自变得更加充实。
Hopefully that makes sense. So how exactly do we do that? How do we achieve this nice symbiosis? Firstly, we need to work on a fundamental mindset shift, which is learning to not fear loneliness or being alone even when it doesn't feel voluntary. Treat your solitude with intention, perhaps even with forced excitement, and it will become exciting. If you look at your calendar and it's looking pretty empty, I know the inclination is to panic and fill it. Instead, I want you to ask yourself, like, what does this give me the opportunity to do instead? What is something that's always just like a little bit better to do by myself anyways? What's something that I do when I kind of, I'm like, I probably shouldn't have invited somebody to do this with me.
希望这能说得通。那么我们到底该怎么做呢？我们如何实现这种美好的共生关系？首先，我们需要进行根本性的思维转变，那就是学会不恐惧孤独或独处，即使这种独处并非出于自愿。带着意图去对待你的独处，甚至带点强作的兴奋，它就会变得令人兴奋。如果你看一眼日程表，发现上面空空如也，我知道你的第一反应往往是恐慌并把它填满。相反，我希望你问问自己，这反而给了我做什么的机会？有什么事情是我无论如何都一直觉得独自去做会更好一点的？有什么事情是我做的时候，心里会想，我刚才其实真不该邀请别人一起来做的？
Do that now. This is not a punishment. You have not failed. This is an opportunity. And it might sound cliche to label it as such, but we know that fundamentally how you experience things begins with how you perceive them. So targeting that aspect first, targeting perception,
现在就去做吧。这不是惩罚。你没有失败。这是一个机会。把它贴上这样的标签听起来可能有点老套，但我们知道，从根本上说，你如何体验事物始于你如何看待事物。因此，首先针对这一点，针对你的看法，
brings more acceptance and enjoyment further down the line. If your perception is, I am so excited for this, I'm so happy that I get this opportunity, enjoyment will increase. Something I try and always think of is that, you know, at some point in the future, I may have kids and my partner will be sleeping next to me in bed every single night and I'll have people needing things from me every hour and I'm most likely not going to have much time to myself in those moments, like when I'm irritated and maybe like a little bit sticky and tired and over-stimulated.
会在以后带来更多的接纳和享受。如果你的看法是，我太期待这个了，我太高兴能有这个机会了，享受感就会增加。我试着经常去想的一件事是，你知道，在未来的某个时刻，我可能有了孩子，我的伴侣每天晚上都会睡在我身边的床上，每时每刻都有人需要我帮忙，而在那些时刻，我大概不会有多少属于自己的时间，比如当我感到烦躁、可能还有点黏糊糊、疲惫且过度刺激的时候。
I am going to be thinking back on my 26-year-old self, Gemma, right now, right here, on how scared she was of spending a night alone, I'm going to beg her to appreciate what she has been missing. I'm going to beg her to be like, just, you don't know what you have. Like, say in tonight, romanticize the privilege of silence and the privilege of solitude. Enjoy this time for what it is. whatever you have to say, do think, believe in in order to flip that switch in your head, from panic to enjoyment when you have a weekend free or an evening free,
我会回想起26岁的自己，此时此地的杰玛，回想起她当年是多么害怕独自度过一个夜晚，我会恳求她珍惜她所错过的一切。我会恳求她说，就，你根本不知道自己拥有什么。比如，就在今晚，把这种沉默的特权和独处的特权浪漫化。去享受这段时光本来的样子。无论你需要说些什么、去想些什么、去相信些什么，以便在你的脑海中拨动那个开关，当你有了一个空闲的周末或一个空闲的夜晚时，把恐慌转变成享受，
do it. Whatever philosophy you need to believe, believe it. It's also so critical to examine what you're really resisting when you refuse to be by yourself. We speak a lot about this idea that big emotions like fear or anxiety, often hide more nuanced secondary emotions that are harder to cope with, like insecurity or instability or emptiness or boredom or existential fatalism, all these things. And I think that our fear of loneliness is a prime example. I don't really think you're afraid of being bored. I think you know that you can cope on your own. I don't think you're afraid of feeling lonely. I think we all know deep down,
那就去做吧。无论你需要相信什么哲学，去相信它吧。审视当你拒绝独处时，你真正抗拒的到底是什么，这也是极其关键的。我们经常谈论这样一种观点：恐惧或焦虑等强烈情绪，往往隐藏着更微妙、更难以应对的次要情绪，比如不安全感、不稳定感、空虚感、无聊感或存在主义宿命论，所有这些。我认为我们对孤独的恐惧就是一个典型的例子。我真的不认为你是害怕无聊。我想你知道自己可以独自应付。我不认为你是害怕感到孤独。我想我们内心深处都知道，
like you're capable of entertaining yourself. The secondary fear that you are experiencing is, what if I get too comfortable with this? Or what if this is a sign of worse to come? What if I lose my agency in my own loneliness or solitude? I think we treat alone time like it's this diagnostic test. A free weekend is not neutral. It is evidence that we are becoming these lonely people.
你是有能力自娱自乐的。你所经历的次要恐惧是，如果我对这种状态感到太习惯了怎么办？或者，如果这是更糟糕事情即将来临的征兆怎么办？如果我在自己的孤独或独处中失去了自主权怎么办？我认为我们把独处当成了一种诊断测试。一个空闲的周末并非中性的。它是我们正在变成这种孤独之人的证据。
You know, if we can't fill it, if we're not busy, this is the end. Like, our mind is building this case, this very fearful, anxious case that, like, I'm never going to find anybody ever again. Like, my friends are disappearing. This is, as I said, the beginning of the end for me. Like, I better, I better get out of here. If I don't get invited now, I'm never going to get invited again.
你知道，如果我们无法填满它，如果我们不够忙碌，这就是终点。你看，我们的内心正在构建这样一个案例，一个非常恐惧、焦虑的案例，觉得我再也找不到任何人了。就像我的朋友们都在消失。正如我所说，这是我走向终局的开始。所以，我最好、最好离开这里。如果我现在没有收到邀请，我以后就再也不会收到邀请了。
The deepest fear is a fear of not just missing out. I think it is that fear of never being invited back in. and of constant exclusion and not having agency in that. And that is very powerful stuff. Be aware of that because it's also not reality. Not getting an invite one weekend doesn't mean your social life is dead for the rest of your life. Another secondary fear that our aversion to alone time is hiding is the fact that when we're alone, we have to confront things that our normally busy, social lives can seal for us.
内心深处的恐惧不仅是对错失的恐惧。我认为那是对永远无法再次被接纳、不断被排斥且对此毫无自主权的恐惧。这是一种非常强大的力量。对此要有所觉察，因为这也不是现实。一个周末没有收到邀请并不意味着你的社交生活在余生中就彻底完结了。我们对独处的厌恶所掩盖的另一种次要恐惧是，当我们独处时，我们必须直面那些我们平时忙碌的社交生活为我们掩盖的事情。
all these other things are going to start coming up without the presence of a distraction. And not just questions to do with your friends or to do with loneliness, but deeper questions to do with your career and life and purpose and money and trauma, being around people constantly means just less of that. It just means that all this stuff that's like really loud feels a little bit quieter. Again, goes to show how much our fear of being alone isn't just a fear of being alone. it is wrapped up in psychological avoidance and it's wrapped up in a pain point that we just really don't want to push. I would also like to include here that being alone also includes being
在没有干扰的情况下，所有这些其他的事情都会开始涌现。不仅是关于你的朋友或孤独的问题，还有关于你的事业、生活、人生目标、金钱和创伤的更深层次的问题，经常和人们在一起意味着这类事情会变少。这只是意味着所有这些听起来真的很吵闹的事情感觉稍微安静了一点。这再次表明，我们对独处的恐惧不仅仅是对孤独的恐惧，它包裹在心理回避之中，包裹在一个我们真的不想去触碰的痛点之中。我还想在这里加上一点，独处也包括
comfortable with silence and not filling it with music, not filling it with podcasts, I hate to say it, not filling it with podcasts or audiobooks or TV. And that is something that I would say all of us are really bad at. But in fact, the science has shown is very good. for us. I have been going on and on about this for a hot minute. So if you're somebody who knows me personally, please just skip this next part because you've heard it over a couple of years at the pub. I'm sorry. I've been really on my high horse about this. But there is all this research coming out about how the average human will not experience silence ever in their lives. Ever. Unless they like go death or something happens, like, they are never going to experience silence. And the sad thing is,
习惯安静，不塞满音乐，不塞满播客，我讨厌这么说，不塞满播客、有声书或电视。我要说的是，这是我们所有人都不擅长的一点。但事实上，科学表明这对我们非常有益。我刚才喋喋不休地讲了好一会儿。所以如果你是认识我的人，请跳过接下来这段，因为你在酒吧里已经听我念叨好几年了。我很抱歉。我在这件事上确实有点好为人师了。但现在有这么多的研究表明，普通人一生中根本体验不到安静。永远不会。除非他们失聪或者发生什么意外，否则他们永远不会体验到安静。可悲的是，
though, our brains really like silence. A study from 2006 from the University of, I think, Parvi or somewhere in Italy, revealed how much our bodies do really appreciate it. The researchers were investigating something very different, actually. They were investigating music and how different types of music across all genres affected stress and affected blood pressure and heart rate and breathing and how music could be used to like emotionally regulate through biological systems. And just by accident, they included a two-minute silence randomly between tracks, just as a control measure. Then it became part of the experiment because it turned out that listening to this silence
我们的脑子其实很喜欢安静。2006年，意大利帕尔维（注：应为帕尔马）大学或某个地方的一项研究揭示了我们的身体究竟有多么感激安静。实际上，研究人员当时在调查一件非常不同的事情。他们正在调查音乐以及各种流派的音乐如何影响压力、影响血压、心率和呼吸，以及如何通过生物系统利用音乐来进行情绪调节。纯属偶然，他们在音轨之间随机穿插了两分钟的静音，仅仅作为对照测量。后来这成了实验的一部分，因为事实证明，听这种静音
elicited the lowest stress marker of all, even lower than during the five minutes of like rest before the test started, where people were kind of just listening to sounds around them. People had their headphones on, and it was complete silence. And they really, they really liked it. Now, what does this have to do with being alone? I guess, I think being alone is more than just not being around people. I think if you want to stretch this muscle more and get even more tolerance, it's also about being alone with your own thoughts. So challenging yourself to, yeah, have an evening by yourself
引发了所有标记中最低的压力指数，甚至比测试开始前那五分钟的休息时间还要低，当时人们只是在听周围的声音。人们戴着耳机，周围是一片绝对的安静。他们真的、真的很喜欢这样。这跟独处有什么关系呢？我想，独处不仅仅是不和人们在一起。如果你想进一步锻炼这种肌肉，获得更高的耐受力，它也关乎如何与你自己的思想独处。因此，挑战自己，没错，独自度过一个晚上，
and not have something playing on the TV. Have a little date night, not play music, cook, don't have YouTube in the background, eat, don't have YouTube in the background. When you spend time alone, and again, I'm kind of, I will say I still, I'm not great at this, but I'm trying. When you spend time alone, don't replace people with other people's voices through a screen. Just be with your own thoughts for a little bit. They're not going to bite you. They're not going to hurt you.
不要让电视里放着什么东西。来个微型约会夜，不放音乐，做饭时背景里没有YouTube，吃饭时背景里没有YouTube。当你花时间独处时，再说一次，我还是得说，我在这方面也不太擅长，但我在努力。当你花时间独处时，不要用屏幕里其他人的声音来取代真人。花一点时间与你自己的想法相处。它们不会咬你。它们不会伤害你。
Something that equally eases us into the enjoyability of being by ourselves is finding something we can genuinely obsess over. I will say this. My alone time became so much more enjoyable when I knew what was waiting for me was really fun. And when I knew that on my table where my watercolors and my cool Japanese watercolor paper and my photo albums and my art projects and my fun things that I found so much more enjoyable when quite frankly, nobody else was talking to me and nobody else was around. Basically, we're talking about hobbies, solo hobbies, will help you so much in these situations because it offers up this inner world that's just for you that you get to step into and get wrapped up in
同样能让我们轻松享受独处乐趣的一件事，是找到一件我们可以真正为之着迷的事情。我这么说吧：当我清楚地知道有什么有趣的事情在等着我时，我的独处时间变得快乐多了。当我清楚地知道我的桌子上摆着我的水彩颜料、我酷炫的日本水彩纸、我的相册、我的艺术项目，以及那些让我觉得无比快乐的有趣东西时，说实话，当时没有别人跟我说话，也没有别人在我身边。基本上，我们谈论的是爱好，个人爱好会在这些情况下对你大有帮助，因为它为你提供了一个只属于你自己的内心世界，你可以走进去，沉浸其中，
and you come out of four hours later and you're like, where the fricked of the time go and you completely figure out how long you were, I don't know, doing terrible watercolors for. And suddenly alone time doesn't feel so scary because you get to experience this enhanced flow state. You actually can't experience with other people. I've just found that like anything that ritualizes my alone time so that I have a routine to it, I have an exact thing I love doing the most when I'm alone, makes it so much more special because it's like a date. I'm like, it's a date. And I've been in a long-term relationship. Like, dating my boyfriend is fun. Dating myself right now is like so novel and so new. And so, yeah, sometimes it's hobbies, but also it's like,
四个小时后你从里面出来，会想，时间到底死哪儿去了，你完全弄清楚了自己到底花、我不知道，花了多长时间在画糟糕的水彩画上。突然之间，独处感觉不再那么可怕了，因为你体验到了这种增强的心流状态。这是你和别人在一起时实际上体验不到的。我发现，任何能将我的独处仪式化、让我对它产生常规的事情——比如我独自一人时最喜欢做的确切事情——都会让独处变得格外特别，因为它就像是一场约会。我想，这是一场约会。而且我一直处于一段长期关系中。和我的男朋友约会很有趣。而此刻和自己约会是如此新奇。所以，有时候是爱好，但有时也是，
he was away for a little bit in Belfast. And I was like, I'm going to go to the movies alone. I'm going to get the luxe seat. And I'm going to smuggle in all my snacks. And I'm going to get pasta and wine. And I'm going to bring my journal. And I was like, this is the funnest thing I've done all year because I made an event of my solitude. I made actual plans with myself, the way that I make plans with my friends. You know, when I make plans with my friends, there are activities and outings, and there's normally a couple of stops and there's food and there's things to be excited about. I think part of our aversion to alone time is that it's oftentimes spent indoors with ourselves, often in our own home, and it's kind of boring, right?
他去贝尔法斯特待了一小会儿。我就想：我要一个人去看电影。我要买豪华座位。我要把所有的零食偷偷带进去。我要去买意面和红酒。我要带上我的日记本。我想：这是我一整年做过最有趣的事情，因为我把我的独处办成了一场活动。我像跟朋友制定计划那样，给自己制定了真正的计划。你知道，当我跟朋友制定计划时，会有活动和郊游，通常会有好几个去处，有吃的，有让人兴奋的事情。我认为我们排斥独处的部分原因在于，它往往是在室内和自己一起度过，经常在自己的家里，而且有点无聊，对吧？
It kind of feels monotonous. If we really want to embrace this, I'm my own best friend. I love my solitude mentality. Your friend, if you're your own best friend, your friend wouldn't just always ask you to come and hang out of their place and do chores. Maybe they would, but not every single time. You know, that's a lazy friend. If every time your friend wanted to hang out with you, they were like, so my place, my place, my place, and let's just go on our phones and do nothing. That's not quality time.
这感觉有点单调。如果我们真的想拥抱这种“我是自己最好的朋友，我热爱我的独处”的心态，你的朋友——如果你是自己的最好朋友的话——你的朋友才不会总是要求你来他们家消磨时间、做家务。也许他们会，但不会每次都这样。你知道，那是个懒惰的朋友。如果你的朋友每次想和你一起消磨时间时都说：去我家，去我家，去我家，然后咱们各自玩手机什么也不干。那不叫高质量的陪伴。
And so if you want to be your own best friend, you can't be the friend who makes those kinds of plans. You need to be the friend who's like, hey, I've organized like a three. stop date for you and I. Like we're going to go to the comedy, we're going to go out for dinner, come back and we're going to do our nails. We're going to do, we're going to do quality time. If you're going to date yourself, you've got to be somebody you would want to date. So somebody who puts an effort, somebody who really like wants to raise the bar for yourself. Basically what I'm saying is if you value quality time with your friends, promote it with yourself as well as your own best friend. You want to take this even one step further. You can also have a location you go to that
所以，如果你想成为自己最好的朋友，你就不能做那种制定这种计划的朋友。你需要做那种说“嘿，我为你和我安排了一个三站式的约会”的朋友。我们要去看脱口秀，我们要出去吃晚饭，回来后我们要一起做美甲。我们要享受高质量的陪伴。如果你要和自己约会，你就必须成为一个你想去约会的人。也就是说，要付出努力，要真正想要为自己提高标准。我基本上想说的是，如果你重视与朋友的高质量陪伴，也请作为自己最好的朋友，把这种陪伴应用到你自己身上。如果你想把这再推进一步，你还可以找一个地方作为你的
is your so-called Church of Solitude. And I saw somebody talking about this concept the other day. A Church of Solitude is a place where you bring no one. Nobody knows about it. It's something that you have a personal connection to. And when you want a loan time, you know you're not going to run into anybody there and you go there. And it's just for you. When I was living in Sydney, there was this massive tree deep in Centennial Park and I swear I saw somebody there like twice and it was very much like they saw me. I think they knew what was up. They gave me space. Went the other way. I did usually have my dog with me and she's pretty freaking massive. So I think they were probably a bit like scared. But maybe played a role. I think maybe they just
所谓的“独处教堂”。前几天我听到有人在讨论这个概念。独处教堂是一个不带任何人去的地方。没有人知道它。那是你与之有着个人联系的地方。当你想要独处时，你知道在那里不会碰到任何人，于是你就去了那里。它完全属于你。当我住在悉尼时，世纪公园深处有一棵巨大的树，我发誓我在那里只见过别人两三次，而且他们显然也看到了我。我想他们心知肚明。他们给了我空间。反之亦然。我通常带着我的狗，它体型非常庞大。所以我想他们可能有点害怕。但也许这起到了作用。我想也许他们只是
knew and maybe we had the same alone space. Like a church of solitude is just like amazing practice. whether it's a cafe, whether it is a spot in your local park, in nature, like somewhere, a bookcase and a museum, I don't know, like a place that you preserve just for you that signifies solitude and all that can bring. And I think also the value of having a place like this psychologically is that when you go there, your brain feels queued up, right? it sends a signal of like this is what we are doing right now we come here for this this is the practice that we are practicing we're going to spend time alone let's sit here let's enjoy it
心领神会，也许我们拥有同一个独处空间。就像“独处教堂”是一个绝佳的实践，无论是一家咖啡馆，还是当地公园里大自然中的某个地方，某个地方，博物馆里的一个书架，我不知道，就像一个只为你保留的地方，它象征着独处以及独处所能带来的一切。而且我认为在心理上拥有这样一个地方的价值在于，当你去那里时，你的大脑会感到受到了提示，对吧？它会发出这样的信号：这就是我们现在正在做的事情，我们来这里就是为了这个，这是我们正在进行的练习，我们要花时间独处，让我们坐在这里，让我们享受它。
and all those positive parts of this mental state and positive parts of this experience that we spoke about you know creativity the wandering mind the intelligence the imagination all come back more strongly because it doesn't take as much time to get into the state when your brain knows that this is what we do when we are in this place, when we are in our Church of Solitude. So think of a place right now that you could go to that is just for you. Schedule on some time and go there more regularly. Okay, we are going to take one more short break. Before we discuss this final kind of element of this, which is, am I spending too much time
而我们谈到的这种精神状态的所有积极部分以及这种体验的积极部分——创造力、天马行空的思绪、智慧、想象力——都会更强烈地回归，因为当你的大脑知道这就是我们在这种地方、在我们的“独处教堂”里时要做的事情时，进入这种状态就不需要花那么多时间了。所以现在就想一个你可以去的地方，它只属于你自己。安排好时间，更规律地去那里。好了，我们要再进行一次短暂的休息。在我们讨论最后一种元素之前，也就是，我花在
alone, the opposite problem? Stay with us. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches. There's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pesto survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.orgia for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsesives, and anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and love island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo, and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story.
独处上的时间是不是太多了，也就是相反的问题？请继续收听。每个为孩子们准备午餐的夜晚背后。都充满了悬念。他们终于肯吃蔬菜了吗？青酱能撑过第一口吗？饭盒带回家时会是空的、半满的，还是根本就没带回来？在你切好黄瓜之前，你能看完第8集吗？获取Bell高速光纤网络，尊享Netflix和Disney Plus，每月只需94美元起。两年期套餐价格保证两年不变，并享有自动扣款优惠。访问bell.orgia了解详情并查询可用性。Bell，连接意味着一切。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的性格同样重要，欢迎回家。这里是Prose Society，这是一档每周播客，既是思想女孩、流行文化痴迷者的读书俱乐部，也是他们的群聊，适合所有认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等水平探讨的人。我是伊莱·拉罗（Eli Rallo），每周我们都在书籍、互联网和每个人都在热议的话题之间建立联系。我得去查查这个故事。
I'm obsessed. As someone says. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place.
我着迷了。正如某人所说。从畅销书作家和您最喜爱的BookTok创作者，到最新的流行文化时刻，一切皆有可能。这就好像如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的讯息，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是想寻找深度文学探讨、聪明的流行文化对话，还是寻找一个喜欢过度思考的读者社区，你都来对了地方。
Listen to pro society on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable.
在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Prose Society。我们在字里行间相见。我14岁时被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，我用一生来探索其他人是如何在理应毁灭他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特（Elizabeth Smart），这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边传来一个低沉、嘲弄的声音说：闭嘴，什么也别说。每周，我都会和经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起。
I knew if he woke up, without a doubt he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman.
我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问他会伤害我。我开始觉得床头有人，然后我开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被剥夺了声音。但这些并不是关于他们被夺走了什么的故事。这些是关于他们如何活着逃出来的故事。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。
I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people. And they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is
我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随意的老兄主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。每次我试图独处时，我都会不断遇到人。他们会说：你对我们笑了。这里没多少人笑。正是在你独处的时候，你才最能接受世界的本原，
and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you got you. your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport.
而不是关于它的谎言。这可以是一个你突破极限、改变想法或唤醒全新自我的时期。所以，无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是太紧张而不敢预订第一次旅行，我都希望你在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。
And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook on the Big Money Players Network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz, and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time, and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman.
还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们在大钱玩家网络（Big Money Players Network）主持播客节目《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。我们的节目对第一次听的听众非常友好。每周，我们都会采访一位演艺界人士，也就是业内人士，试着帮他们发展事业，看看他们能给我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为公关人员让他们上我们的节目而生气。我们有很多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·谢尔曼（Sarah Sherman）。
Not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head? Right? How about we flip the script? Okay. What is the surprised woman who actually you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird? Adam Scott.
没那么好。其实，你能帮我塑造一下这个吗？我们把它反过来怎么样？对吧？我们把剧本反过来怎么样？好吧。那个你以为是个老实人的、吃惊的女人，其实才是行为怪异的那个人？亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）。
This entire time, you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to visit the show. I would never expect. I have. I would never set expectations for something like that to happen. If the universe allows for something like that to happen, I'm. I'm open to it. I'm always going to accept. You know, Danny McBride, fine.
这段时间以来，你一直期待亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）来节目做客。我绝不会期待。我有。我绝不会对这种事情的发生抱有期望。如果宇宙允许这种事情发生，我是。我是持开放态度的。我总是会接受的。你知道，丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride），行吧。
Yeah, it's all this fragile masculinity exuding. I could smell it walking down the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, is that weed? Nope, it's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times out of context, people don't get it or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? They're like, oh, what's a state.
对，这散发着所有脆弱的男子气概。老实说，我走在走廊里就能闻到。我想，那是大麻吗？不，是脆弱的男子气概。本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），不行。因为很多时候脱离了语境，人们根本无法理解，甚至不知道什么是圈子。你知道我的意思吗？他们会想，哦，什么是状态。
Everyone's so dumb except for you. And fake. Right. fake and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got my life. I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
除了你之外，所有人都这么蠢。而且很虚伪。对。虚伪而且毫无兴趣，或者只是，哦，我有我自己的生活。我才不管你的生活呢。还有许多其他的大人物，如果没有我们，他们根本不会有今天。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）亲自告诉我们他喜欢这个节目，他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他实在是太忙了。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Hollywood Handbook》。
Okay, so maybe you are listening to this episode and you are thinking, I've done all this. I actually was too good at this. I took this advice too seriously. And I've gone in the opposite direction. I spend too much time by myself. Is that a problem? I think the biggest question to ask yourself is, do you think you have a problem? What do you think? Are you actually lonely? Or are you just enjoying a more independent error? Because those two things are very different things. And the the research does back that up. It backs up this idea that voluntary versus involuntary alone time are very different. There's this man, he's a researcher's named John Capaccio, and he actually, fun fact, co-founded the field of social neuroscience decades ago. He also spent a lot of time studying loneliness,
好吧，所以也许你正在听这一集，心里在想：我已经做完这一切了。我其实做得太好了。我把这个建议看得太严重了。结果我走向了反方向。我花在自己身上的时间太多了。这算是个问题吗？我认为你需要问自己的最大问题是：你觉得这是一个问题吗？你觉得呢？你真的孤独吗？还是你只是在享受一个更加独立的时代？因为这两件事截然不同。研究确实也支持这一点。它支持这样一种观点，即自愿的独处与非自愿的独处有很大不同。有这样一个人，他是一位研究员，名叫约翰·卡波西奥（John Cacioppo），事实上，趣事一件，他几十年前共同创立了社会神经科学领域。他还花了很多时间研究孤独，
and he made that same distinction, that very important distinction, that loneliness isn't about how much time you spend alone. It is about the gap between the social connection you have and the social connection you want. Hence why it is so subjective. The number of hours you spend by yourself isn't actually as diagnostic or helpful as you think. Your subjective experience is much more helpful. Hence that question, do you think you have a problem? You are the only one who can tell, are you happy the way you are? Do you feel like you get enough social input? If so, maybe you do only need two to three days a week or even less of seeing people. That being said, there is a point where solitude can tip into something else. And researchers do are a very helpful line here
他也做出了同样的区分，这个非常重要的区分是：孤独并不取决于你独自度过了多少时间，而是取决于你拥有的社交联系与你想要的社交联系之间的差距。因此它是如此的主观。你独自度过的小时数其实并不像你想象的那样具有诊断价值或帮助。你的主观体验要有用得多。因此才会有那个问题：你觉得你有什么问题吗？只有你自己能分辨出来，你对现状满意吗？你觉得自己获得了足够的社交输入吗？如果是这样，也许你真的每周只需见两到三天的人，甚至更少。话虽如此，独处确实有一个临界点，可能会演变成其他情况。研究人员在这里划定了一条非常有帮助的界限：
between solitude as a state, unsociability as a personality trait, and social withdrawal as a symptom. Solitude is temporary and it's voluntary. You can slip in and out, you can make choices about it, you can enjoy it. Unsociability is a preference. You also enjoy it, but it's more of like, you know, you don't always choose it because it's just who you are. You very much rather read a book than go to a party, even if you're invited. Maybe you'll go, you enjoy yourself, but your preference is to be alone. Social withdrawal is different. It's when you are pulling back from people because social interaction feels very threatening or heavy or exhausting, even though, that is not typical for you. And social withdrawal is what we really want to look out for. In these situations,
将独处作为一种状态、将不合群作为一种人格特质、以及将社交退缩作为一种症状区分开来。独处是暂时的，而且是自愿的。你可以进出自如，你可以对此做出选择，你可以享受它。不合群是一种偏好。你也会享受它，但它更像是，你知道的，你并不总是选择它，因为它就是你的本性。哪怕收到了邀请，你可能也更愿意读本书而不是去参加派对。也许你会去，你也会玩得很开心，但你的偏好仍然是独处。社交退缩则不同。它是指当你开始疏远人群，因为社交互动让你觉得非常具有威胁性、沉重或精疲力竭时——尽管这并不是你的常态。而社交退缩正是我们需要真正警惕的。在这些情况下，
I think it often indicates that there has been some experience, some broader pattern in the past, recent past is pushing you into a space or into a pattern of behavior that you aren't actually comfortable in. I think we see this a lot of time after a bad breakup where you're just like, I just cannot be around people or when you're going through grief or a bad friend. situation has left you a little bit traumatized. You have an innate desire for connection and for more social interaction, but interacting with other people just feels harder than it ever has before. You just can't do it. You want it, you don't. You want it, you don't. No matter how tricky it feels, we have to remember social skills like most skills can atrophy and kind of break down with disuse.
我认为这往往表明，过去曾有过某种经历、某种更广泛的模式——最近过去的经历——把你推向了一个你其实并不适应的空间或行为模式。我认为我们在一次糟糕的分手后经常会看到这种情况，当时你只会觉得：我就是无法和别人在一起；或者当你正在经历悲伤、或者糟糕的朋友关系让你变得有点创伤。你内心对建立联系和更多社交互动有着强烈的渴望，但与他人互动却变得比以往任何时候都更加艰难。你就是做不到。你既想要，又不要。你既想要，又不要。无论它感觉多么棘手，我们都必须记住，社交技能就像大多数技能一样，如果长期不用，就会萎缩和退化。
There's a lot of research suggesting that prolonged isolation can actually make future social interactions feel more and more effortful and more anxiety provoking because we're out of practice. And so then that reinforces the need for withdrawal. It reinforces the fact that we shouldn't be around people. It's called a biosocial psychological feedback loop. A lot of fancy words to basically say that when we get into the habit of not being around others because we think that it's scary or hard, the more scary and harder it becomes. So again, you know best.
有很多研究表明，长期的孤立实际上会让未来的社交互动感觉越来越费力，并且更容易引发焦虑，因为我们生疏了。然后，这反过来又强化了对退缩的需求。它强化了我们不应该和人们在一起的想法。这被称为生物-社会-心理反馈循环。用很多华丽的词汇，基本上就是说当我们习惯了不和别人在一起，因为我们认为这很可怕或很困难时，它就会变得越发可怕和困难。所以，再次强调，你最了解自己。
Sit with it a bit. And if you think, you know, I'm just in an independent error and I'm trying to find my balance and I'm just swinging this other way for a little while, maybe you're all right. But if there's been this gradual avoidance, if there's social anxiety behind this, remember that being around other people
稍微静心体会一下。如果你认为，你知道，我只是处于一个独立的时代，我正在努力寻找平衡，我只是朝这个相反的方向摆动了一小会儿，也许你一切都好。但如果这种回避是循序渐进的，如果这背后存在社交焦虑，请记住，与他人相处
is often a lot harder in imagination than reality. Remember that there are a lot of people out there who do really like you. and really enjoy you and really, really enjoy your company, no matter what your brain is trying to convince you right now, even if it's 30 minutes with a friend, just make sure you have something on your radar. Make sure that there is something that you like to do that is social, because I want to remind you of that kind of very critical thing we said earlier, the better you get at spending time alone, the better your relationships should become. The better your relationships are, the less
在想象中往往比在现实中要困难得多。请记住，外面有很多人真的很喜欢你，真的很欣赏你，并且真的、真的很享受你的陪伴，无论你的大脑现在正试图让你相信什么，哪怕只是和朋友相处30分钟，只要确保你的雷达上有一些社交活动就行。确保有你喜欢做的、带有社交属性的事情，因为我想提醒你我们之前提到的那个非常关键的观点：你越擅长独处，你的关系就应该越好。你的关系越好，
being alone should feel like a punishment. Really, they operate in unison. So if you're spending a lot of time alone, but your relationships really aren't improving, something's kind of off balance. If you're spending a lot of time with other people, but loneliness and alone time starts to feel like this abyss that like you can never step towards, something's also off balance as well. But that, my friends, is our episode and kind of my guide to how to get better at being alone, semi-colon, without going too far. I think the concluding summary headline of this episode is really, if you can control your relationship to solitude, you can control so many of your other reactions.
独处就越不应该感觉像是一种惩罚。实际上，它们是协同运作的。所以，如果你花了很多时间独处，但你的人际关系真的没有改善，那就说明有些地方失衡了。如果你花了很多时间与其他人在一起，但孤独感和独处开始变得像一个你永远不敢靠近的深渊，那也说明有些地方失衡了。不过，朋友们，这就是我们这一集的全部内容，也是我关于如何更好地独处（分号）而又不走向极端的指南。我认为这一集的总结中心语实际上是：如果你能控制你与独处的关系，你就能控制你的许多其他反应。
A loneliness no longer feels like a threat. It no longer feels like something that is, held over your head by bad, unfulfilling relationships. Doors open because you can go through them alone and reveal more opportunities to do things because you don't need a partner. You don't need somebody else there to be your companion or to co-regulate you through that. You may even experience, as we said, greater levels of intelligence, greater levels of creativity, which is very rarely spoken about. Each of us has that set point of time we need to spend around others. So respect that need, respect your introversion, your extroversion. Don't entirely deny yourself friendship and
孤独不再感觉是一种威胁。它不再感觉是被不良的、无法满足的关系悬在头顶的东西。大门敞开了，因为你可以独自穿过它们，从而展现出更多做事的机遇，因为你不需要一个伴侣。你不需要身边的某个人来做你的同伴，或者在那种情况下陪你进行自我调节。你甚至可能会体验到，正如我们所说，更高水平的智力和更高水平的创造力，而这一点极少被人提及。我们每个人都有需要与他人相处的时间设定点。所以，请尊重这种需求，尊重你的内向或外向。不要完全剥夺自己的友谊和
connection, but if you're sitting with a sense of guilt or fear that you don't have as many plans as other people do, that you're wasting your 20s, that you should be busier, I think that this is your permission to let that fear go a little bit and to know that that's actually really, really normal. And no matter what you see online, people are spending a more time by themselves than you think. And doing so, opting into that, that's your choice, but you do have a lot to benefit. So thank you for listening. Thank you for making it all the way through. Thank you to our researcher, Lucy Davidson, for her contributions. Hey, if you have made it this far and you're listening on Spotify, leave a comment down below. What is your Church of Solitude?
联系，但如果你心里带着一种负罪感或恐惧，觉得自己的计划没有别人多，觉得自己在浪费20多岁的年华，觉得你应该更忙碌一些，我想这是在给予你许可，让你稍微放下这种恐惧，并知道其实这真的、真的很正常。无论你在网上看到什么，人们独自度过的时间都比你想象的要多。选择这样做，这是你的选择，但你确实能从中获益匪浅。谢谢大家的收听。谢谢大家坚持听到最后。感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）做出的贡献。嘿，如果你已经听到了这里，而且你正在Spotify上收听，请在下方留个言。你的“独处教堂”是哪里？
What is the place that you go all by yourself that nobody else goes to? I gave you mine. I did. I gave you mine. So I'd love to hear yours. Make sure to check out an episode on Netflix as well. The full, I guess, transcript article version of this is now on Substack. If you want to join us over there, it's popping off, I will say. There are a lot of people hanging out with us on Substack. And I would love for you to be one of them. Instagram, my book, everything else is in the description. But I loved this episode. I loved getting to talk to you guys about this. Especially my little rant about silence in the middle. Thanks for enduring that. But I hope you enjoyed it as well and learned something. So until next time, be safe, be kind,
你独自一人去、而其他人都不去的地方是哪里？我分享了我的。我确实分享了。我分享了我的。所以我也很想听听你们的。请务必去Netflix上收听一期节目。本期的完整文字记录文章版本现在已经在Substack上了。如果你想加入我们，我得说，那里现在正火爆呢。有很多人在Substack上和我们一起玩。我希望你也能成为其中一员。Instagram、我的书、其他所有东西都在简介里。但我很喜欢这一集。我很喜欢和大家谈论这个话题。尤其是中间关于安静的那段小唠叨。谢谢你们的忍耐。希望你们也喜欢并学到了一些东西。所以，直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，
be gentle to yourself. Thank you for tuning in. We will talk very, very soon. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita,
对自己温柔一点。感谢收听。我们很快就会再聊。在全新播客《Solita》中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随意的老兄主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，
trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart and these are the Survivor Files. Every week I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
用可能性取代同情。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。我经历了长达九个月的被囚禁生活，我用一生来探索其他人是如何在理应毁灭他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特（Elizabeth Smart），这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会和经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起，他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被剥夺了声音。
These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport and Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook. Each week we talk to someone in Jop. show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stillard,
这些是关于如何死里逃生的故事。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听由伊丽莎白·斯玛特主持的《幸存者档案》。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特和肖恩·克莱门茨。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主持人。每周我们都会与演艺界的人士交流，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，并看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，也没有人因为公关让他们上我们的节目而生他们的气。我们有很多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·谢尔曼、亚当·斯科特、丹尼·麦克布莱德、本·斯蒂勒，
and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Our hometown is not a test tube. 90 miles northeast of Nashville, a battle for the future of America plays out in one small Developers with right-wing ties have purchased hundreds of acres of land. We need cities on a shining hill. This is Our Town, a podcast about what happens when a small town becomes the site of a social experiment and fights back. Guess you didn't move in on a bunch of dumb hillbillies now, did you?
以及许多如果没有我们就不会有今天成就的大人物。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。我们的家乡不是试管。在纳什维尔东北部90英里处，一场关于美国未来的争夺战在一个小镇上演。有着右翼背景的开发商购买了数百英亩的土地。我们需要山巅之城。这是《我们的小镇》，一个关于小镇成为社会实验场并进行反击的播客。我想你们现在发现搬进这里来的不是一群傻山民了吧？
Listen to Our Town on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我们的小镇》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的性格同样重要，欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一个每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊，适合所有认为《傲慢与偏见》和《求爱岛》值得同等程度探讨的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、图书创作者以及大量过度思考的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴联系起来。我着迷了。我着迷了。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。